plus de cinq ans ont passé depuis que
cette torontoise a perdu son fils le
jeune homme atteint par balles à la
sortie d'une discothèque et est âgé de
26 ans
le traumatisme est encore bien réelle et
elle confie qu'elle continue à chercher
de l'aide aujourd'hui cette autre mère
torontoise avec qui il s'est lié
d'amitié a elle aussi perdu son fils à
cause de la violence armée il a été tué
devant leur maison en 2017
au début le choc est tel que mes
capacités motrices mes aptitudes
cognitives ont été affectés dit elle il
suffit de coups de feu pour que la vie
de multiples personnes soit ainsi
bouleversé à jamais et en plus des
victimes directes et leurs proches c'est
souvent toute une communauté qui est
ébranlé par une fusillade et qui a subi
le traumatisme parfois
intergénérationnel rappel cette
intervenante communautaire
or il manque cruellement de services de
soutien pour toutes ces personnes
déplore-t-elle c'est aussi le constat de
cette députée provinciale qui a déposé
un projet de loi privé cette semaine
pour réclamer plus de programmes à la
fois en milieu hospitalier pour prendre
en charge les blessés mais aussi en
milieu communautaire
un suivi psychologique approprié elle
souhaite que ces services soient
couverts par l'assurance santé
il s'agit d'une crise de santé publique
résume-t-elle et c'est de ce point de
vue que la province doit s'y attaquer
d'autant plus que personne est à l'abri
aujourd'hui de la violence armée qui
peut arriver n'importe où à toronto
rappelle cet activiste que ce soit dans
un centre d'achat ou une fête d'enfants
comme un modèle et moreno
7,2 tweets en
or si on abandonne ceux qui en subissent
les répercussions aujourd'hui disent ils
on risque de contribuer au cycle de
violence de demain ici camille guiraud à
radio canada toronto